barack obama
bruce springsteen start a podcast yes
together okay
a president and a rock star start a
podcast it's going to be called
renegades born in the usa
as part of a multi-year partnership with
spotify brock and michelle obama's
production company higher ground
spotify's deal with higher ground
announced june in june of 2019 was one
that's earlier big bets in the podcast
industry earlier the same year spotify
acquired
podcast studio gimlet media okay got it
so how do you think this is going to go
with these guys start a podcast together
by the way somebody said adam is
officially a 9-4
i just want you to know that adam also
just got five dollars for a porsche 911
that's right we only need 4.95 for the
rental valuetainers will support it but
bruce springsteen's gonna start a
gofundme for adam can i get can i get
from uh
eight point five to an eight point to a
potential nine point two million porsche
not quite oh no no you pull up in a
porsche 94 does not round up to ten fyi
nine
you you pull up with a porsche you
you're getting close to a dime
absolutely wow this is what's happening
yes so it's an impression by the way yes
so now
barack obama bruce springsteen how good
is it gonna do okay number one that's
potentially gonna be the number one
podcast on the planet
other than ours okay clearly especially
when we talk about
uh the you know the cars 911. you have
you have
um i can't think there's two parts of
this story here and then i'm gonna turn
it over to the lovely danielle dimartino
booth
renegades born in the usa you don't
think that's like a
birther joke like come on trump born in
the usa
two-term president really don't think
they're going there well i think that's
exactly where they go number one
bruce springsteen's greatest hit is
arguably born in the usa
and born in the usa springsteen one time
trump was playing it he said i don't
want you to play that
exactly there's a shot here at trump by
the way there's a hundred percent a shot
here at tropical yeah
i see that's what i'm saying absolutely
that's exactly what i'm saying trump
obviously rose to power
through birth arthur on the birtherism
thing
born in the usa renegades so
i think he's going right at trump and
don't don't
think that obviously we talked about
governors being competitive and
to become president you need to be
competitive i'm sure presidents
are the most competitive and if trump
and obama are ever in a room together
you know obama's going to be like
two terms baby two terms born in the usa
fist bump i'm out drop the mic you've
seen him drop a mock mic i'm just
thinking
yeah that's where he's at with that do
you think he's gonna do good
oh gosh i mean who doesn't love bruce
springsteen
i'm sorry is somebody else involved this
guy named
barack hussein obama oh sorry yes i'm
i'm sure he'll be a nice
accoutrement for he's the he's the side
dish to bruce
briggs sings main dish but who's gonna
have better stories
i think obama's the i mean he's gonna i
think obama you take off your politics
hat
and you know maybe he inhales once or
twice in his life i don't know
i'm you know i'm speculating answer
twice that's what i'm saying like these
days not once or twice lets his hair
down maybe
puts a little afro sheen in that thing i
think he could have a
great set of stories i think it could be
really fun
so so then the question becomes the
following what okay i'm going to throw
something out there for you
he had me at afrosh wait but but hear me
out so
so by the way coming to america two is
coming out this weekend speaking of soul
glow in africa
so so renegades born in the usa obama
and springsteen yes
say a year from now another podcast gets
started trump and kid rock
who wins wow that would actually be
wrong
podcast or obama and
you know what i'd love to see that i
would love trump and kid rock or
somebody like that to start a podcast
kid rock is pretty loud as well so if
they started it together
and they have it to see how competitive
these two podcasts are awesome
and eminem hates uh trump but but rock i
think but if
kid rock and trump did it obama
and bruce stewart who wins actually who
wins what do you think i
actually think trump would win you think
trump would win i think
listen as much as i'm not a fan of trump
people are tuning
in to this what that monster has more
than obama
yes okay yeah wow i'd agree with you but
there's one reason why
i think trump would say more kind of
outlandish things which is what you
often want from the podcast
it's the shock factor what do you think
you have me here listen
um to make history baby howard stern
said it and said it best people that
love howard stern listen for an hour
why because they want to hear what he
says next people that hate howard stern
listen for an hour and a half why
because they want to hear what he has to
say next
you know you said it earlier in the show
media ratings are down
because trump's not around people want
to hear what he has to say next it's
outlandish it's ridiculous it's divisive
it's racist whatever you want to call it
if it bleeds and leads they want to hear
what it has to say let me
tell you do you think there's any chance
he starts a podcast
do you think there's kai turn off your
mic do you think there's any chance he
starts a podcast i think with trump
there's a chance for anything
okay so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye